à 2°grés pour prendre quelques autres
exemples la totalité des coros tropicaux
sont morts euh à 2°grés probablement
plus de la moitié de la forêt française
est morte à 2 degr on perd en moyenne 20
% d'humidité des sols euh sur tout le
pouretour du bassin méditerranéen France
comprise et ça et peut-être même plus
voilà quelques exemples euh de de
conséquence d'une élévation de de 2
degrés d'ors et déjà même à 1, quelque
chose degré on a déjà mis en route par
exemple la fonte du Groenland et donc
maintenant il suffit d'attendre quelques
siècles et on sait que l'océan mondial
montera d'au moins 3 à 6 m voilà rien
qu'à cause de ça donc VO voilà quelques
exemples